if you live in Japan and managed to sign
up for the beta then you might be able
to get in on the Pokemon go beta
starting today the Pokemon game where
you catch pokemon in real life launched
in japan through a field test if you
signed up for the beta but you haven't
been invited yet there's still a chance
you can get in in a google plus update
translated by IGN the developer niantic
says it plans to gradually expand the
field test and invite more players will
give you more information about the
lottery system and invitation based on
your device and your experience of real
world gaming you've had so far those
invited will be sent the details via
email however for those who have not
received an invitation police stay
excited as we are gradually expanding
the field test the field test will come
to other countries potentially the US
and Europe at a later date so if you're
in the US like me there's still a chance
we might be able to play pokemon go a
little bit early the free-to-play game
will be supported by microtransactions
and it will launch in full later this
year niantic will also be releasing a
bracelet that will buzz when a Pokemon
is nearby it's like a real-life poker
radar for more Pokemon go news keep
those pokeballs aimed at gamespot
you